[Musique]
et oui cette semaine fouilles de sujets
sont venus se percuté violemment alors
on dirait que c'est toujours la même
histoire et que c'est le propre de
l'actualité de remplacer un événement
par un autre mais ce qu'on appelle c'est
quand je les communique en politique ça
commence à ressembler de plus en plus à
la chienne généralisé qui se propage à
toute vitesse car en ce sens bien que la
France est en train de chasser de la
roue arrière en se rapprochant
dangereusement du fossé alors que volant
l'ensemble de la classe politique se
refait une petite beauté dans le
rétroviseur alors oui il faut y prêter
une attention particulière car tous ces
petits événements sont les signes
avant-coureur d'une situation qui
devrais m'inquiéter au premier chef le
gouvernement car tous les symptômes d'un
grand malaise national se retrouve dans
l'actualité de ces derniers jours et les
noms des plaines à Olivier Véran un test
en doliprane politique de 7 jours ne
suffiront pas à endiguer une très
probable un très probable choc infection
nationale et nous allons essayer ce
matin de décrypter cette situation qui
pourront à court terme déclencher
déflagration inquiétante est
préjudiciable
[Musique]
alors commençons par un sujet les j'ai
tout autant qu'il en est désespérante
unique pour la droite dit républicaine
car le parti des républicains est en
arrêt cardio-respiratoire
car et aussi je me suis obligé ces
derniers jours et même depuis un mois à
regarder les indigents débat pour la
primaire entre Xavier Bertrand Valérie
Pécresse Éric Ciotti Philippe Juvin et
Michel Barnier mais mon dieu mais quel
ennui mais quelques années qu'elle
sacerdoce quelle perte de temps
d'écouter Michel être d'accord avec
Xavier qui lui-même est d'accord avec
Valérie si elle reprend ce qu'a dit Éric
et qui précède ce qu'a dit précédemment
Michel et Xavier en est en train
d'assister ni plus ni moins au plus
ridicule naufrage politique
avec celui de la 5e République j'ai
l'impression d'avoir assisté au grand
taureau du concours Lépine des inepties
politique et les seuls bénéficiaires de
séjour au formol ont dû être quelques
instants trouver rapidement le sommet en
écoutant C4 des bars en réalité cette
droite républicaine l'a proposé et
brasse du vent et elle devrait se
dépêcher de rédiger son testament
politique est envoyé son préavis de
départ mais c'est grâce au hara-kiri
politique il y a les fondement des
républicains que la candidature d'Éric
Zemmour et aujourd'hui possible et cette
candidature fait monter une
stérilisation et de violence politique
dans le pays comme on a rarement vu dans
notre histoire il n'est pas question ici
de gloser sur la candidature d'Éric
Zemmour médecin qui était qui m'a qui va
devenir de plus en plus dans les jours à
venir et qui pourrait connaître une
poussée de fièvre lors du premier
meeting candidat ce dimanche à Paris ou
des rassemblement de manifestants en
qu'ils aient Morcenx attendu et il est
aussi bien entendu comment ne pas en
parler c'est interdit du candidat sur
TF1 qui a ravivé les braises certains
l'on considérait à charge et a juste eu
raison car il faut le dire on attend
autre chose comme on reçoit un candidat
élection suprême quel qu'il soit sur une
grande chaîne national bon on passera
sur la vidéo déclaration la
présidentielle et des problèmes présumé
de droit à l'image qui les km apparaître
un certain amateurisme dans son équipe
de campagne en tout état de cause des
tensions autour cette candidature sont
en train de mort c'est la France en deux
blocs irréconciliables et cela ne fait
les affaires de personne et surtout pas
des Français
[Musique]
latitude gouvernement est un élément
crucial cette équation très dangereuse
la déclaration de Gérald Darmanin qui a
quality la vidéo d'Éric Zemmour
absolument ignoble je si tu n'es pas un
signe d'apaisement elle en mm absurde de
son côté Emmanuel Macron lui semble
convaincu qui peut tirer parti cette
confusion de cette tension et de
situation anxiogène ces de nombreux
français aujourd'hui comme hier son
absolu et de continuer à se servir de la
crise sanitaire et d'un discours
alarmiste avec le Var au micro-ondes
contredit d'ailleurs récemment pour l'
OMS pour consolider son électorat cette
dramatisation de la crise sanitaire
permet aussi de poursuivre une politique
discriminatoire entre les Français et de
continuer à imposer impasse absolument
tragique pour notre cohésion nationale
et nos libertés fondamentales d'ailleurs
d'ailleurs on attend toujours que le
gouvernement baigne répondre à la CNIL
sur l'efficacité du pas sanitaire et sur
la protection des données donc à
l'attention de Jean Castex il pleut
adresser son courrier à l'adresse
suivante à 3 place de Fontenoy à Paris
mais c'est en tort c'est un peu comme
les gestes Bayern gouvernement on perd
or on déclare on oblige dans la réalité
on ne les appliques pas à soi-même alors
oui la Concorde en de ces événements
doit nous faire craindre le pire si
collectivement nous continuons à se voir
mais comme le disait Michel Audiard pour
finir je cite entre l'international les
abus de confiance il y a une marche